[Música]
y el directo a América llegó el momento
de hablar de economía por ello le doy la
bienvenida a mi compañero Jorge Hurtado
Jorge qué tal Muy bien Andrés y vos Bien
también Jorge vamos a iniciar hablando
de Ucrania el fondo monetario
internacional aseguró que la economía de
este país es resistente aún a los
ataques rusos contra su infraestructura
y el organismo también aprovechó para
anunciar un nuevo préstamo por 900
millones de dólares y elevó su
estimación del crecimiento económico
para ese país las perspectivas positivas
para cerrar este año en Ucrania entre el
1% y el 3% de crecimiento del pib frente
al menos tres Y al más uno de la
evaluación que habían estimado en marzo
pasado los especialistas afirman que la
inflación en Ucrania está bajando y la
moneda local Aún es estable pese a la
guerra el fmi asegura que Ucrania
cumplió los requisitos para reformar las
políticas económicas en el marco de una
primera revisión de lo que será un
paquete de préstamo de 15.600 millones
de dólares a lo largo de cuatro años
Aunque un primer tramo de ayuda de 900
millones de dólares se acordó a nivel
personal aún requiere la aprobación del
directorio ejecutivo del fmi recordemos
que la producción económica de Ucrania
se contrajo alrededor del 30% en 2022
tras la invasión rusa en febrero de ese
año Jorge Nigeria enfrenta horas de Caos
luego de que el nuevo presidente
anunciara el fin de la subvención del
combustible bueno el nuevo presidente
dijo que el presupuesto para 2023 no
incluye subvenciones para el combustible
Nigeria que es una nación rica en
petróleo intercambia crudo por gasolina
que luego subvenciona a su mercado
interno esto provocó una enorme fuga de
ingresos y Divisas contribuyendo a
disparar la deuda más de 80 millones de
los 210 millones de habitantes del país
pide por debajo del umbral de la pobreza
según el Banco Mundial el nuevo
presidente y exgobernador del estado de
lagos prometió una limpieza a fondo de
la política monetaria a partir del
próximo junio entre los retos de su
gobierno está una gran deuda pública
escasez de Divisas y combustible y por
supuesto la inflación más alta dos
décadas bien Vamos a cambiar de tema
vamos a ir ahora a Francia donde se
inauguró la primera fábrica de baterías
para vehículos eléctricos de la región
de padecale el ministro francés de
economía Bruno lemer aseguró que se
trata de la creación de un nuevo sector
Industrial por primera vez desde la
creación de airbus la compañía
automotive sells operará Gracias a la
unión entre estas llantis total Energy y
también Mercedes Benz el inicio de la
producción está previsto para el verano
y la comercialización para finales del
2023 en Europa el sector Automotriz está
apostando por la electrificación con la
ayuda de un gran apoyo público y también
acelerado por esta prohibición de los
vehículos de combustión en la Unión
Europea a partir del 2035 este grupo
empresarial sería uno de los primeros en
producir baterías para carros eléctricos
en Europa en la actualidad hay alrededor
de 50 proyectos de este tipo que han
sido anunciados en Europa en los últimos
años con el fin de depender mucho menos
de proveedores asiáticos sobre todo
chinos que representan más del 80% de la
producción mundial de baterías para
vehículos eléctricos bien vamos a pasar
ahora a Estados Unidos Hablamos ahora de
Elizabeth Holmes la responsable del
fraude de veteranos Que ingresó a una
prisión en Texas bueno esta mujer como
recordemos creó un startup tecnológica
que prometió revolucionar los análisis
de sangre y atrajo a inversiones por 9
mil millones de dólares hace 8 años
Holmes tenía 31 años de edad y era la
fundadora presidente y consejera
delegada de terrenos una empresa que
prometió revolucionar la medicina
Gracias a una tecnología que permitía
hacer un análisis con una muestra de
apenas una gota de sangre pero todo se
trataba de un fraude con el que estafó a
cientos de inversores la empresa nunca
desarrolló esta tecnología según reveló
el periodista John carrear del Diario de
Wall Street journal hasta el martes ella
estaba en Libertad bajo fianza en 2018
el departamento de Justicia Estados
Unidos acusó a Holmes y a su pareja de
varios delitos empresariales y hoy
ingresó esta presión donde cumplirá una
condena de 11 años un caso bastante
mediático Jorge y también la empresa
inviria se convirtió en la novena
compañía en llegar al billón de dólares
en el en valor de mercado si se trata
también del primer fabricante de chips
en lograr este hito las acciones de la
empresa volvieron a subir tras un
excelente informe de resultados empujado
por el auge de la Inteligencia
artificial la valoración de un billón de
dólares de envidia la convierte en la
quinta empresa estadounidense más
valiosa por detrás de Apple Microsoft
alphabet y también Amazon envidia que es
conocida por sus chips utilizados en
videojuegos apostó hacia el mercado de
los centros de datos en los últimos años
el negocio creció durante la pandemia
cuando despegaron también los
videojuegos se disparó la adopción de la
nube y los promotores de las
criptomonedas buscaron sus chips para
minar criptoactivos el negocio de chips
para centros de datos representó más del
50% de los ingresos de la empresa en el
ejercicio financiero que terminó el 29
de enero ahora con el auge de la
Inteligencia artificial la empresa
volvió a ganar los grandes ordenadores
que procesan los datos e impulsan la
Inteligencia artificial generativa
funcionan con potentes chips denominados
unidades de procesamiento gráfico y
nvidia produce alrededor del 80% de
ellos Jorge muchas gracias por la
información económica a vos nos vemos en
la próxima Así es así ustedes
televidentes también gracias por
acompañarnos no se desconecten que ya
viene el debate
[Música]